joe biden is promising to guide america
out of what he calls
the season of darkness but he may be
having trouble convincing some of the
progressives in his own party
that he has seen the light correspondent
peter ducey reports tonight from
wilmington delaware
this is how joe biden pitched himself in
a speech
he's waited decades to give i'll be an
ally of the light
not the darkness
just outside horns honked and headlights
flashed as invited guests watched the
democratic nominee
formally accept the nomination socially
distanced
from their cars the morning after a
first on the campaign trail a
golf cart parade for joe biden at the
villages in florida
all week long convention organizers
tried to project harmony
among moderates and progressives but one
of the most prominent progressive
speakers
was never actually asked by convention
organizers to appear
and only had time in the show because
bernie sanders asked
her to second his nomination alexandria
ocasio-cortez
i think what the dnc was saying is oh
you know she's speaking
no i mean they didn't invite her i think
they should have that's a whole other
story
sanders was all smiles with former
rivals last night
why does my girlfriend like you more
than she likes me
but let's be closer she wants more than
you but wasn't ultimately pleased with
the whole program
the story is they should have had more
progressive speaking giving them
speaking spots
many speakers including the now nominee
devoted significant time to attacking
president trump
president keeps telling us the virus is
going to disappear
he keeps waiting for a miracle well i
have news for him
no miracle is coming but republican
critics
say all the trump talk left some
questions about
biden's platform democrats just spent
four days
in a convention and i don't know one
thing is on their agenda except they
dislike this president
and they're going to raise your taxes
one of the closing night's most
moving moments came from a new hampshire
teenager
hi my name is braden harrington and i'm
13 years old
and without joe biden i wouldn't be
talking to you today
brayden met biden in february seeking
advice about something biden struggled
with as a young man
a stutter you're going to see this kid
become president united states of
america someday
six months later brayden had a global
platform
kids like me are counting on you to
elect someone
we can all look up to now the rest is up
to biden
but while i'll be a democratic candidate
i will be an
american president
and just 15 minutes ago a brand new
biden interview conducted this afternoon
here in wilmington dropped
abc news asked him if he would shut the
country down
during a covent spike if that was what
scientists recommended biden said this
quote
i would shut it down i would listen to
the scientists
and that represents yet another
clear-cut difference between biden
and trump about one of the issues that
voters care about
the most right now brett peter ducey
live in wilmington peter thanks more on
this with the panels